we're gonna talk about this paper by
Sean Carroll Sean Carroll's a wonderful
writer if you're not familiar with his
books in his blog I thoroughly recommend
them it's Sean's take on the the
multiverse idea but it's beyond that as
you can see it says beyond
falsifiability so the multiverse thing
we've done before in sixty symbols
Mike Mary fields looked at that I think
my views on a multiverse probably align
pretty close to Mike's my personal
opinion is that the the reality of
things requires there to be some test
that somebody could do but not quite as
complimentary and it's quite a support
of perhaps as Sean's views but he makes
a very good case I recommend this it's
available in the archive work very well
written paper but what I'm going to talk
about today is not multiverse it's
actually this thing called
falsifiability so I took it on a train
with me to read it I've read it a few
times this there was a phone number
written down here which I didn't want to
broadcast across the Internet hence I
ripped that bit off I've scribbled on it
scribbled on it quite a bit I like this
paper so I teach a four-tier margin
which is called there let me get the
peas in the right order their politics
perception and philosophy of physics and
actually I tell the students who want to
do it if you don't like writing do not
do this module but it's about exploring
the types of ideas that Sean Carroll is
covering in here
particularly the idea of in inverted
commas the scientific method capital T
capital s capital and toward a prime
wish school you know what's the
scientific method well you set up an AI
potus's and then you test that
hypothesis you gather evidence and then
you either confirm or you deny that
apophysis Lord I wish it were that
simple science is so much messier than
that and this idea that you know you can
get the killer result or the killer
experiment and that completely wipes out
the field and we've got a paradigm shift
etc science really is about a great deal
more messiness and uncertainty and
uncertainty is actually built into the
fabric of experimental science one thing
we spend a great deal of time with
undergraduate students certainly in
Nottingham but every single undergrad
of course / students in first year are
driven to destruction in terms of
considering experimental uncertainties
and experimental error bars it has to be
weighed in a balance that can measure
microscopic quantities this idea that we
get these incredibly precise
measurements sometimes yes we get you
know a precision but the precision is
always got an uncertainty associated
with it everything in the laboratory is
frequently tested for radioactivity
what's interesting here in terms of what
Shawn Shawn Carol is doing is teasing
apart this idea falsifiability
because it's held up as sort of almost
tenets of faith what what's
falsifiability mean I guess I need to
get to that first the idea of
falsifiability was introduced by Karl
Popper so popper was not at all happy
with this idea of having an apotheosis
that you test because he made the
argument that it's very very difficult
to verify a theory that way so he came
at it from the other tack he came at it
from the opposite direction and he said
well really what we should be doing here
is we set up a theory and the first
thing we should ask ourselves is let's
be good scientists let's be
hypercritical how would we disprove this
theory how would we knock this blow this
theory out of the water and that's the
idea of falsifiability that if something
isn't falsifiable in the proper sense
therefore it's not scientific so here's
a glimpse inside the mystery building
where many hundreds of scientists live
and work this idea that you have that
killer definitive experiment that the
popper would say will not falsifies your
theories so that's a definite born it
doesn't happen it does not happen like
that I would say it that actually we
very very rarely if ever set up an
experiment whereby we have an hypothesis
and we want to test that hypothesis
often were exploring the vast majority
of the time we're exploring we might
have some idea we might have a grant
application we might be going in a given
direction we might set up or you know
Gantt chart and our ideas at the start
in terms of how we're going to map out a
time line three months in we've gone off
in another direction generally and
that's because science is messy how does
such a discovery start
well a really good example I hate to use
it but it's because it's now almost a
cliche but it's a very important example
graphene that was what happened with
graphene how was that discovered of all
that incredibly wonderful 2d physics all
the credible links to particle physics
that's ever basically after noon Friday
afternoon possibly a rainy afternoon -
like this sellotape scotch tape I think
the call in the u.s. pulling off sheets
of graphite to get down to that single
single atomic layer but for them to then
look further and say let's get out the
microscope whatever and see what we've
done there must have been like a
hypothesis yes yeah those were no
potus's in the sense of let's go and
have a look at this but not let's go and
look at this and see whether we can
disprove whether there's something on
this that's that's not toggles or let's
go and have a look at this and we're
looking for that key falsifiability
criterion so you're not scorching the
scientific method you're sketching I am
scotch I am sketching as always said
scratching that's a good word scratching
the scientific method capital T capital
S capital n I would say that depending
on which lab you're in depending on
which community and the way you do
science is very different from another
community so I would not approach as a
physicist I would not approach an
experiment the same as a biologist what
or as a social scientist would even if
we did approach experiments like that
even if we did have this falsifiability
criterion the question is is you go what
we falsify this experiment how do you
know how do you know that if somebody on
the other side of the world repeats the
experiment and the way you did that they
will get the same result you don't
actually know in that sense science
proves nothing
science is fundamentally uncertain you
can have mathematics and you can have a
deduction and you know you can have
deductive proof stamps proofs stemming
from those mathematics the way we work
in science you know we have a series of
samples we measure measure measure
measure measure measure we got a bigger
sample size if we're sort of working in
a more social level and we assume that
those you know the statistics of this
experiment are gonna be general when in
fact we don't really know we don't know
if we measure 100 samples at 100 and
one sample we don't have a deductive
proof to say that the 101 sample is
gonna be the same
similarly this idea that you know you
can have the killer evidence I can sit
for scientists around this table I can
give them it's exactly the same piece of
evidence exactly the same experimental
date have an image of molecules or
whatever if it's in nanoscience some
data related you know some new particle
etc whatever and I can almost guarantee
there will be different interpretations
so how do we choose which are the right
interpretations I mean I don't think
it's breaking news though that in almost
any industry the ideal and the tenants
of that industry whether it's accounting
or filmmaking or whatever someone does
has this kind of Platonic ideal and the
reality of it is a bit messy and why
should science be any different yeah is
it still not as a general theme
scientists are having ideas and
gathering evidence to test their ideas
or are you saying that's just that's not
even at the core of it no I would say
that scientists are certainly you know
you're having ideas they're exploring or
certainly gathering evidence to try to
support one theory or another and what I
would say is compared to those other
industries not so very good obviously
there are different working methods and
the stuff that you know happens behind
closed doors the problem is science and
quite rightly science has held up to a
greater level of scrutiny in terms of
the evidence base and the scrutiny and
this degree of criticism and cynicism
and so the problem is the sort of for
life from that is that science has
become this I like the way you said
platonic so it's sort of almost this
ideal this utopia whereby you know this
is the this is the way you do science
you know and this is hope you know
you're taught in school this is the way
you set out your processes you do none
nna you come to the end you verify or
and it's so much messier than that and
so there's the issue with sort of
getting the killer theater really comes
down to how does it ciri survived
certainly some of that some of it is due
to the strength of the evidence and
strength of the data but you can have
very strong evidence from very strong
data and if the prevailing sort of
opinion within a community is in the
other direction
you're gonna have to fight really hard
particularly if you're a small group if
you got a world-leading group or a
number for leading groups going this is
the paradigm that works and you have a
small group or Europeans D student or
you're trying to get it through you're
gonna have a hard time so this is what
Carol is getting out here I love this
the way in which we judge scientific
theories is inescapably reflective messy
and human that's the reality of how
science is actually done it's a matter
of judgment not of drawing bright lines
between truth and falsity or science and
non science that's so important because
there is this idea that you know well
science is so incredibly objective and
at some level once you get you know
evidence piling upon evidence of you
sort of reached the point where it's
almost an inescapable conclusion and I'm
not suggesting that you know you can go
very far along one direction where
there's something called cultural
relativism who would proponents of that
would would argue that actually
everything is societally biased that
that every particular measurement is is
related to the culture in which it's
made I'm not going that far but I am
thoroughly agreeing with Carol here and
also this arrived for me today a friend
bought me this social physics by Alex
Pentland there's a great have already
read quite a bit of it over lunch as
we've seen so far in this book new data
are changing this argument and we are
now this is really important we are now
coming to realize that human behavior is
determined as much by social context as
by rational thinking or individual
desire desires rationality as the term
is used by economists means that we know
what we want enact to get it but my
research Pentlands research shows that
both people's desires under decisions
about how to act or often and perhaps
typically dominated by social network
effects you're kind of stoking the fires
of people like climate change deniers or
flat earth people are all these people
who say scientists are pulling the wool
over our eyes you're basically saying
well yeah scientists not only say no no
look at the evidence we've got this
robust system so you should trust our
results and you're now saying it sounds
to me like you're saying you can't trust
us I'll put the question in the same
question to you as I put two the fourth
years when I
I teach this module so are you would you
consider yourself a climate change
denier no okay so you'd consider that
there's sufficient evidence out there to
support the idea of climate change I
sort of trust the scientists there you
go there you go and I when I asked the
class the fourth-year class that's
exactly I'm certainly not suggesting for
one second that I'm denying the evidence
behind climate change from me in terms
of what I've looked at there's very very
strong evidence for climate change but
somebody who isn't a scientist or for
somebody who's outside the field I am
done the simulations I haven't analyzed
the data at some level I am taking it on
trust and faith that there's a consensus
here and therefore I'm going with that
and now you're telling me don't trust
the consensus because no I'm not saying
that I'm so you're saying sometimes if a
scientist comes up with a paradigm
changing result if they're a small group
without clout they can't change the
prevailing belief I didn't quite say
can't I said we'll find it very
difficult and they will but in the
important thing is despite my skepticism
about the scientific method couple of T
capital s capital M it still works
you know what still works you know if I
do an experiment here drop this and
measure the acceleration due to gravity
so many Japan does the same measurement
give or take and experimental error
borrowing taken into account you know
different positions of you we get the
same result that's remarkable
that's that's really remarkable but like
anything almost like anything in life
it's not this black or white it's a
spectrum and it's shades of gray and so
you've got to build in that as well as
the those objective results and that
representative theories like the
multiverse for example a big element of
it is is how convincing your argument
can be what journals are you publishing
what type of coverage are you getting
will you and BBC you CNN and set foot
surfer all those type of things
all those type of social activities
playing are you saying that the
scientific method shouldn't be taught to
young people at school I'm saying no I'm
not saying that at all I'm saying in
terms of collecting evidence thinking
about experimental design thinking about
how you're gonna analyze you did all of
those I would suggest it needs to be
broadened out a little bit to say that
instead of there being a definitive
scientific method there's a spectrum of
people how people do science and get
them to think about it you know for one
thing when I go into primary schools for
example one thing I say about being a
scientist is great thing great part of
my job is what do I spend when I can get
into the lab what do I spend my time do
playing and an awful lot of scientists
they might not meet it but that's what
they're doing they're playing so when
we're manipulating atoms moving them
around that's great fun of course
there's you know key scientific elements
of that and of course you get insight
into how matter is behaving but it's
great fun as well so the social element
is best right into the fabric of just
how we do science and the idea that you
can disconnect the sort of human aspect
of us from the science that's what
you've been doing for years pretty
showing that you know you scientists are
human as well so what's the film or
reality scientific method every you say
every five does have a different method
what's yours
poke and prod until you find something
basically you're saying you wouldn't
want to see how we make the sausage no
no I'm saying precisely the opposite I
would say come in the lab see how we
make the sausage science is all about
honesty science is as Fineman said I
hate to quote Feynman because you know
everybody quotes behind them but there's
a reason everybody calls Feynman science
is about bending over backwards to prove
yourself wrong so you know you should be
open you should be honest you should get
people in the lab and one of the issues
as we get more and more sort of
commercially focused is that you know
proprietary issues become and people
want to hide the date or not really
shared with offer competition with Allah
that's a real shame it's a winner that
will and dollars for Britain and the
grateful thanks of patient and doctor
everywhere ring people in the lab you
get in the lab you've been in the lab
ready you know how messy it is you said
firemen said that it's about bending
over backwards to prove yourself wrong
but you told me just a couple of minutes
ago that you don't do that that you
don't you don't have an etic finding and
then spend the next six months trying to
falsify I would say in in in the context
Feynman means there maybe he meant
popper but I think he's meaning what I
was saying in terms of you know where's
the noise have we your first reaction
should be we've screwed things up and
then work back from there and try and
and find out only when you've eliminated
this this this this there
this and this do you then start to think
what possibly maybe we've got something
here I think that's the sense finally
Afghan if it's beyond me I say that
because if there were only a finite
number of possibilities quantum
mechanically then in an infinitely old
universe all of those possibilities
would happen over and over again an
infinite number of times and this
relates back to another important
question in cosmology you know the arrow
of time why is the past different from
the future